morning all a-level students across
england wales and northern ireland are
waking up this morning to their results
after more than two years of schooling
thrown into turmoil by covid19 thousands
of pupils are facing lower grades than
last year when of course they were
assessed by teachers and competition for
university places is expected to be
fierce but the ambition service ucas
says a record number of students are
still expected to get onto their first
choice courses
scores of students also receiving their
b-tech and t-level results as well who
better than to speak to about all of
this than the education secretary james
cleveland cleveland great to have you in
the program
it's a it's an awful moment sitting on
days like this i do go back to getting
my own sys results many many years ago
how is it going this year
well we
firstly i want to say huge
congratulations to the students because
as you said in your introduction they
have
they've experienced a really tumultuous
couple of years and they've they've
really worked hard to get to where they
are at the moment uh so we've got exam
results that will be coming out later on
uh this morning um the the marking
process has gone according to plan the
exam process has gone according to plan
there'll be uh i think
lots of students
perhaps even the majority of students
able to get into their first choice
institution
um and so uh you know we're feeling the
plan that we've put in place has uh we
believe worked
waiting for results of course but but
just in terms of the the the broad
outline of those results i mean we are
seeing uh results coming down compared
to where we were last year significantly
the so off qual um we've been working
very closely with and the plan was
always to get those grades back to the
kind of levels that we were seeing
before the pandemic they were more
generous and i think that's legitimate
but they were more generous during the
pandemic years it was always the plan to
get them back um that is going to be
seen this year so students might get
slightly lower grades than perhaps they
were expecting and that they were hoping
but as i say i think we should see the
you know the
majority of students get into the
institutions they want to i i suppose
the question and it's been a question
that's been posed by a number of people
is whether or not this kind of
educational cohort the class of 2022 was
the correct year in which to get grades
back in line with kind of pre-pandemic
levels they have not sat an exam their
studies have been completely crucified
thanks to the pandemic and remote
learning and so on and we know that
across the country the impacts of covet
differs depending on depending on how
much money is floating around in an area
so just justify the decision to kind of
make this lot of students deal with it
rather than next year
well
as you say
this this group of students had a really
tough time that's why i congratulate
them so much
um and we put adaptations in place so we
made sure that the exams were fair we
gave uh greater spacing between the
exams just in case students did contract
covid which put pressure on the marking
bodies but they've stepped up to
their responsibilities but but funnily
enough it was the students themselves
who were most vocal in their desire to
ensure that they had qualifications
which were fair but robust and taken
seriously by both by institutions and
employers and whether it be a levels or
the new t levels that are coming out
this year or other vocational training
that's what we've achieved but just to
return to the point about the disparity
i mean fft education data lab that
published in times educational
supplement earlier this year there is a
north side split when it comes to
education pupils in the northeast
missing 15.3 percent of lessons compared
to just 11.6 percent of lessons lost in
london when there is such a marked and
statistically significant regional
disparity why is it fair that we treat
all pupils this year in the same fashion
well the the thing that we have got to
do is get back to
a school-based teaching and exam based
assessment
this year we've taken a step towards
normality we have still had mitigations
in place there are adaptations during
the exam and obviously we have injected
a lot of money into making sure there's
catch-up tuition which will probably
benefit the cohorts coming in
after this one to be fair but
nevertheless this is what the teaching
profession is what the students this is
what employers and institutions want
we've done it in a progressive and fair
way and i think today what we'll see is
a lot of students um getting into the
institutions they want to get into or
into the apprenticeships or into the
jobs that they
are going to be moving into
let's we will return to discussing i'm
sure the a-level results once we've got
once we've got the data and we've had
the chance to go through it but could we
just talk just in general terms about
your approach to schools i mean pretty
clearly there are incredible financial
pressures on everyone at the moment but
particularly in the educational sector
we've seen teachers getting a much trump
a much trumpeted pay rise five percent
for existing uh eight percent for new
staff but that money's coming out of
existing budgets we saw cpi getting to
10.1
yesterday isn't this now the time to say
that we need to see a significant and
serious expansion of our schools budgets
well what we have seen is a very
significant expansion already um it's
worth remembering that in the
spending is lower in real terms than it
was in 2010 yeah but what we what we
have uh seen through this uh spending
review period is a seven billion pounds
uplift into this school's budget four
billion of that coming into this next
academic year we completely recognize we
completely recognize there are cost
pressures uh on schools the the uh the
the majority of schools budgets of
course is uh staff pay and the award
that the uh the school system received
was in recognition that there was going
to be an upturn in in teacher business
the schools they're going to have to pay
for it it's the schools they're going to
have to pay for the increased energy
increased energy bills i mean we've got
a situation where what two and five head
teachers at the moment are are
suggesting that they will be forced to
cut teaching staff in their schools in
order to make the budgets work so again
i ask you we know that there's going to
be an emergency budget come september no
matter whether it's liz trusser or rishi
sunay what would you need to see in that
budget in terms of a payroll in terms of
a rise in the the budget for the for the
dfe that would actually balance all this
out well as i say we've we've we got a
very good settlement we've got a
generous
settlement the ifs which holds the
government to account very robustly has
said that they believe that the pay
rises are affordable within the
financial just about affordable but they
do also warn that next year looks
problematic yeah and and that's why
whoever wins uh has committed to have an
emergency budget and it wouldn't be
right for me to preempt that but we do
recognize that there are cost pressures
we do recognize
that school leadership is going to need
to make some um
really important
decisions about expenditure but as i say
we we had a good settlement during the
sr period and the ifs who as i say holds
to account very robustly has said they
believe that these are affordable yeah
and also pointing out that next year is
going to be rather difficult the problem
is of course that all of these costs are
coming and they're continue to increase
as i say we've got two and five head
teachers saying they're looking at
looking at cutting staff i just think
that there are people genuinely come
questioning the conservative party's
commitment to education there have been
six education secretaries since these
a-level a-level kids started secondary
school justine greening damien hines
gavin williamson the dean zahaway
michelle donald lincoln you'll have
mister and and of course yourself only
gavin williamson lasted
longer than two years in post
yeah reassure me what were the
conservatives committed to secondary
education when you go through education
secretaries so
well i can't i mean i i can't uh
uh be held accountable for the duration
of my predecessors in their tenure but
what we can say is you know this badge
the t levels this is about the uh
increased commitment to really really
good quality vocational training we've
seen uh as i say that that good sr
settlement we've seen an increase in the
pay of starting teachers to attract the
brightest and the best into an
incredibly important
profession i've spoken with uh the heads
of the teaching unions the heads of
academies um to to you know to thank
them for the work that they've put in
over these really really tough times we
absolutely recognize that education
unlocks benefit not just for the
individuals but society as a whole yeah
actually schools have have had the
covert compliance ventilation installed
here
so i don't have that figure uh off the
top of my head but the point is that
what we know we know that schools have
shown a remarkable amount of resilience
and adaptation school you know children
have been
possible it's not very many at all
children have been back at school uh
over the last over the last couple of
years we've seen that we can have
children in school being educated being
examined keeping them safe and healthy
that's what uh schools have already
shown themselves capable of doing and
you could so you could have ventilation
installed that was promised months ago
so the point was the point we're saying
is schools have demonstrated that they
can teach that students can learn and
they can do so safely in a covered safe
way they've shown they're already able
to do that that's what we want and
expect them uh to do and you can and i
know uh you know you want to focus on
this particular element but the point
i'm saying is schools have shown that
they can
teach students safely
with the uh circumstance they currently
got i'm just wondering with schools you
know looking unable to pay their fuel
bills whether come the winter time we
will once again be asking schools to
open windows in lieu of ventilation
units that this government has promised
well as i said schools have already
demonstrated that they can safely teach
children within a covered environment
that you know we we've seen that happen
that is why students have been at school
which is great it's the best place for
them to learn indeed which is why they
have been able to sit exams which is the
best way of assessing how much they've
learned and which is why today we are
going to see
hundreds of thousands of happy students
getting into their first choice
institutions and plenty of others going
to great universities or apprenticeships
or employment using clearing or clearing
plus or the other
advice and assistance that the uh that's
available to them well i'm sure the head
teachers union would if you can find an
answer to that question about how many
schools have had that uh have had
covered suitable ventilation installed
but we just talked a completely off
topic uh well off your brief i should
say um we're about to see another set of
rail strikes only one in five trains
apparently uh running today
the rmt making it pretty clear that
there needs to be a significant increase
in the offer uh in the offer for their
for their members what is your view on
on the frequency of these strikes and
indeed what they are asking for
well
we should remember that the uh the the
rail unions
are there to look after their members
and whether it's the current head of the
rail union or bob crow in the past
they've done that very effectively um
they've got a very very good salary
package they have incredibly good
ridiculously good terms and conditions
and what they're doing through these
strikes is they are disadvantaging
people trying to get to work trying to
put food on the table trying to keep a
root over their
roof over their heads um i think grant
chaps has made it absolutely clear that
these strikes are are unfair and
completely inappropriate and it's wrong
that people are held hostage um by the
unions uh in this way and i i do also
just want to quickly ask you about liz
trust and her plans to cut taxes we've
talked already about the ifs uh this
morning and and how diligent they can be
i mean they've said this about liz trust
policies indeed of mr sunic as well hard
to square the promises that both are
making to cut taxes over the medium term
with the absence of any specific
measures to cut public spending
it does feel
that the the the tax policy which has
been a big big part of of liz trustee's
campaign isn't quite hitting the
economist in the way that it's hitting
the conservative party membership
well liz has made it absolutely clear
that this is about stimulating economic
growth you grow the economy
you can take a a slightly smaller slice
of a
slightly bigger pie or hopefully a
significantly a bigger pie that's very
very well established uh economic theory
and frankly what we have seen is growth
in the uk economy not be as vibrant as
we would like that's what liz is is
pursuing is a growth strategy and if you
don't have a plan for growth you don't
have a plan for government is the point
i would make but ultimately today
i'm here with my education secretary hat
on
and actually seeing this group of young
people getting these results um moving
forward into the world of work or uh
further and sorry higher education
these are the people that are going to
help fuel that economic growth uh and i
congratulate them enormously for the
hard work they've put in over the last
couple of years but with your cabinet
minister senior member of government hat
on we just talk about the cost of living
crisis and and again we saw yesterday
cpi 10.1 probably up to 13 by the end of
the year incredible amounts of money
being spent already on our energy when
you have a director of off gem resigning
from their post because they feel that
the
the ombudsman is incapable of managing
the situation there's a fundamental
problem with the way the market is
working isn't there well what we what we
are seeing globally and the inflation
that we're seeing right across europe
across
america across the developed world
driven
in large part by russia's invasion of
ukraine
is is is something as they driven by an
exceptional specifically
fit for purpose
well look um i i i've not had a chance
to read the full statement of the uh of
the regulator i saw the headline that
they resigned but
i think unsurprisingly i was focusing
very very much on making sure the
education system unless you had unless
you had concerns about off-gen before
you read that headline i mean do you
have confidence in it but in its ability
to work as an organisation well i'm
going to read properly the um the the
point that's made i've been i've been
focusing as half teachers as have
universities i've had as have off qual
and ucas and you know everyone involved
in education on this incredibly
important point of view i've rather have
my blinkers on i have to confess on this
one because it is so important we had a
plan it seems that plan is is is working
and um
once we get through the today and next
week when the gcse results have come out
i'll be able to focus more broadly on
the full spectrum events happening but
at the moment my focus has been on the
young people mr squiggly great to have
you thanks for being with us
uh let's have a very quick look at what
is making the papers and we begin with
the times
and it's reporting the tens of thousands
of school leavers could miss out on
their first choice university in part
because of tough a level rates as
according to the times
the ft has word of inflation exceeding
10 for the first time in 10 years
here's the guardian it says that 45
million people could find themselves in
fuel poverty as a result of the cost of
living crisis
the daily express warns of a shock rise
to interest rates facing homeowners
describing ministers as being on a war
footing
now let's get a little bit more now on
the morning's exam results a levels out
today at dan whitehead at the ucas
headquarters in cheltenham at for us
this morning i suspect there'll be quite
a few calls being answered there today
yeah it's around about 40 minutes or so
before the phone lines open here at ucas
in cheltenham they are expecting in
excess of 20 000 students to be
contacting the clearing system it's not
just on the phones which would be a
manned uh by the team behind me here
they are trained to chat to those
students through facebook messenger
through twitter
and other social media channels of
course that's how everyone is getting in
contact these days as they get their
results that nervous weight
this morning to find out exactly how the
students have done and as you've been
saying this morning it's been an
incredibly a different year and a
difficult couple of years for the
students getting their results these are
the
first students to have actually sat an
exam since the 2019 exams at pre
pandemic but they've had an incredibly
disruptive couple of years in terms of
their learning with having their gcse's
cancelled as well so it's been a tough
time for them and we are expecting
grades to be lower than last year but
hopefully higher than 2019 when the last
time that those exams uh were sat that's
all part of a planned and managed
transition to try and normalize
the grades back to pre-pandemic levels
as i say around 20 000 students expected
to contact the team here there are
nearly 30 000
clearing spaces and it's the job of the
guys behind me getting set up on the the
phones here and on their computers to
help those students not only find a
place
at university
in the forthcoming year but also they
are trained to help them emotionally
this will be
a difficult morning for many students
some of course will be celebrating one
of the officials actually said that they
get phone calls from students calling up
to double check they can't actually
believe the results they've got but
because of the predictions of
potentially lower top grades this year
there will be students who will be
missing out
on the places that perhaps some of the
more established top grade universities
and they will be disappointed in looking
at those options so the phone line's
open between 8 and 8 15 here at ucas and
around 270 volunteers are getting ready
to to answer those inquiries provide
that emotional
support and guide those
young people about what their options
will be for this september
dan much more from you throughout the
morning i'm sure thanks very much indeed
um still look to come on the program uh
we'll be speaking to the head of the rmt
union magazine in the middle uh mick
lynch
as real workers go on strike breaking
more travel chaos today and into the
weekend
as students and their parents absorb a
level results i'll be speaking to
labour's shadow education secretary
projections
and a little later on i will be heading
back to cheltenham speaking to the chief
executive of ucas as students are told
to prepare themselves for lower grades
now rail tube and bus passengers are set
to face four days of travel misery as
tens of thousands of workers stage
another round of strikes
well similar to other walkouts we've
seen this summer 40 000 workers
including 20 000 from network rail are
expected to strike train operating
companies across england wales and
scotland are set to be affected by the
industrial action
it will continue into the weekend
transport for london employees striking
on friday r t union workers striking
again on saturday major disruption is of
course expected across the network
to add a little bit of pain for london's
commuters 1 600 bus drivers members of
the united union and employees of london
united at will they plan to strike on
friday and saturday as well
sabah chaudhary uh joins us now from
london houston at the picket line itself
and sam i'm sure you've been speaking to
some of those on the picket what is it
that are actually looking for
good morning neil wealth
more strikes of course the result of
failed negotiations uh between trade
unions
and network rail this is what they are
talking about here this is what they are
striking for today tens of thousands of
railway workers are striking from
various different unions we're talking
network
sorry rmt the united union and 14 other
train
operators are striking today and this is
for things like
better pays what they want they're
saying
increase better working conditions and
also
job security there's equally another
strike happening tomorrow but this one
is more london centric and this is going
to be at london underground and london
united bus drivers that will
be striking now we understand that uh
about 20
of travel will be resumed so there are
significantly reduced services but
that's of course to be expected and also
the strikes that we will be having today
and tomorrow will spill into uh the
following day as a result now transport
secretary grant shaps has said that
trade unions
are
hell bent on causing
misery amongst businesses saying that
it's having a significant
knock-on effect onto things like the the
summer uh tourism trade in the capital
meanwhile the secretary-general of the
rmt nick lynch who is here at the picket
line is saying that the offer that they
were given is just simply not good
enough it's not an improvement and as a
result his union will not be accepting
that offer they are not going to be
bullied or hoodwinked he said into
accepting uh that what is currently on
the table now this offer is one that
network rail is saying is good and it's
fair but that's clearly not what the
unions or most of the unions
are saying now the general advice is to
avoid travel
if commuters can
but otherwise to check what other
options are available
thanks indeed
and just a reminder i will be soon
speaking to the real union boss mick
lynch joining us
from the picket lines
now labour has accused the government of
being asleep at the wheel after a
director of off gem quit just talking
about that with james cleverley in fact
christine varnish said the regulator was
favoring businesses over consumers with
a rule change that she said will lead to
much higher bills
responding to christine farnish's
resignation the energy regulator said
this due to the unprecedented energy
crisis ofgem is having to make some
incredibly difficult decisions where
carefully balanced trade-offs are being
weighed up all the time but we always
prioritize consumers needs both in the
immediate and long term
the statement continues the rest of the
board decided a shorter recovery period
for energy costs was in the best
interests of consumers in the long term
by reducing the very real risk of
suppliers going burst which would then
keep yet more costs onto bills and add
unnecessary worry and concern at an
already very difficult time
some of the day's other headlines now
and we begin with some breaking news in
the last hour a 44 year old man has been
arrested on suspicion of murder
following the fatal stabbing of thomas
o'halloran the 87 year old was killed in
west london whilst riding a mobility
scooter on tuesday
the us government has said it will start
talks with taiwan about a possible trade
deal it follows extensive chinese
military drills in the region as beijing
steps up pressure on taipei to accept
its sovereignty claims
officials in ukraine say that seven
people have been killed after shelling
in the city of harkeef with at least 16
more injured
it comes as president zielinski prepares
to meet the u.n secretary general
antonio gutierrez along with the turkish
president wretched erdogan in the
eastern city of lev later today grain
exports and concerns about the zaparisia
nuclear power plant are expected to top
the agenda
a leads university student has been
sentenced to 34 years in prison in saudi
arabia because of her activity on
twitter
salma al-shahab a mother of two was
detained earlier this year in january
while on holiday for sharing posts about
activism in the country
one of britain's richest men has said he
is serious about wanting to buy
manchester united businessman sir jim
radcliffe already owns two football
clubs nice in france and lausanne sport
in switzerland he also owns a cycling
team it's reported that the cubs club's
current owners the glazer family are
considering selling a minority stake in
the club
now with two and a half weeks left
before the new prime minister is elected
sky news has carried out one of the
biggest opinion polls of conservative
party members with yougov our deputy
political editor sam coats has been
finding out what the party expects from
the next prime minister
the battle for number 10 the main tv
inquisitions now over over half the
conservative membership have actually
voted so what's the state of the race
sky news has teamed up with yougov to
find out and here it is on the basis of
this liz truss will be heading into
downing street on september the 6th she
gets a commanding lead 66
say that they would vote for her 34 say
they would vote for rishi sunak now
that's actually a slight tightening on a
couple of weeks ago but nothing like on
the scale that richie sunnah would need
to overtake liz trust in this contest
let's look at what's happening
underneath the bonnet and those people
who have already voted which is about
six and ten thirty-one percent say they
voted for rishi sunak 68 to say they
voted for liz trust
even bigger lead there for liz trust
what about people that haven't does
rishi sunak have a chance well he
amongst people who haven't yet voted 29
say that they voted for him 44 say they
voted for liz trust but look at this 26
say they don't know that needs over half
of these people to go to rishi sunac's
corner in order for him to have any kind
of chance the numbers just are so
difficult at this stage
but what are the challenges that whoever
takes over will face this poll gave us
some clues the affection that this party
has the conservative party for boris
johnson evident in this we asked what if
boris johnson was actually on the ballot
paper and he wins by a landslide 46
percent say they'd vote for him 24 for
liz trust 23 for richie sunak this group
of people the conservative party quite
good they don't think boris johnson
should have been slung out of number 10
at all in this poll
but what of the toxicity of this race
lots of mud slinging but has it
rebounded on the membership well the
answer appears yes for a big minority we
asked whether liz trust should include
richie sunak in her cabinet 52 say yes
but look at this over a third of the
conservative party say that the man that
took the conservative party and the
government and the country through the
pandemic and wanted to be prime minister
should be left out
of the next prime minister's cabinet
that's quite a degree of dislike of
hatred uh that the next prime minister
is going to have to contend with along
with all the other challenges of the
cost of living crisis i think putting
the conservative party back together is
going to be very difficult for whoever
enters number 10 on september the 6th
sam coats there now floods have left
homes businesses and streets underwater
in parts of the uk as thunderstorms
continue to batter the country
thunderstorms continuing at downpours
and in fact caused flooding inside at
london's victoria station
and outside king's cross downpours had
hit the country earlier in the day
there you see the uh the very regularly
used gym of the houses of parliament uh
flooded out there
people are however being urged to steer
clear of about 40 beaches and swimming
spots in england and wales after the
heavy rain overwhelmed sewage systems
the campaign group suffers against
sewage say that england southwestern and
southern coasts are the worst affected
public outrage has certainly grown in
recent years about raw and partially
treated sewage being pumped into rivers
and coastal waters
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
quick look at the impact of climate
change on the planet uh the right of
your screen there the way in which the
national grid is making its power at 55
of it coming from gas this morning 15
from nuclear on the top left you can see
just how much
warmer the planet is since records began
at creeping up closer to 1.26 and
they're at the bottom left at total
carbon dioxide emissions in millions of
tons if you can believe it
uh time for us to have a quick in see
how the weather is looking
welcome back big day for plenty of young
people a level results out this morning
and speaking to the program the
education secretary said the plan was
always to get those grades back to their
pre-pandemic level james cleverley did
acknowledge it had been a difficult time
for the current cohort but said the
government had put in measures to make
sure these exams were fair
the plan was always to get those grades
back to the kind of levels that we were
seeing before the pandemic they were
more generous and i think that's
legitimate but they were more generous
during the pandemic years it was always
the plan to get them back
that is going to be seen this year so
students might get
slightly lower grades than perhaps they
were expecting and that they were hoping
but as i say i think we should see the
you know the
majority of students get into the
institutions they want to i i suppose
the question and it's been a question
that's been posed by a number of people
is whether or not this kind of
educational cohort the class of 2022 was
the correct year in which to get grades
back in line with kind of pre-pandemic
levels they have not sat an exam their
studies have been completely crucified
thanks to the pandemic and remote
learning and so on and we know that
across the country the impact of covert
differs depending on depending on how
much money is floating around in an area
so just justify the decision to kind of
make this lot of students deal with it
rather than next year
well
as you say
this this group of students had a really
tough time that's why i congratulate
them so much
and we put adaptations in place so we
made sure that the exams were fair we
gave
greater spacing between the exams just
in case students did contract covid
which put pressure on the marking bodies
but they've stepped up to
their responsibilities but but funnily
enough it was the students themselves
were most vocal in their desire to
ensure that they had qualifications
which were fair but robust and taken
seriously by both by institutions and
employers
to discuss that and much more as you can
see our political correspondent maddie
cass is here morning amanda i mean it
would be education secretary well at the
last count you know six or seven of them
uh since 2017 but they've got a
significant issue to deal with and there
will be criticism and i was putting to
mr cleverley there the idea that the
class of 2022 had to be the ones that
had to deal with this
this grade what would you call it great
deflation well indeed i mean they really
are the ones taking a hit i mean if you
look back at it before covid the number
of students getting the highest grade
there was a target of around 20 percent
that's now gone up to 45
so as we heard from him there you know
there he's unapologetic about the desire
to kind of bring that down again but as
you say this is the cohort they've been
hit hardest by covid and they really are
taking the hit from everyone else um he
there insisted that students themselves
uh want to see um this great deflation
as he put it i guess that remains to be
seen later on when we do start hearing
from students beginning to get those
results
labor though have been very critical of
the government's approach i mean they
say this is a cohort who've been failed
at every turn the government still
haven't got their act together to put a
fair recovery plan in place as you were
saying you know some parts of the
country were much more affected by the
covert disruption
than others and there was this big
tutoring program that was put in place
but only one in five students have had
access to that now meanwhile um
mr cleverley did acknowledge that there
is a real pressure on school budgets as
well but said he wasn't going to preempt
any any budget by a future uh prime
minister which rather links us into the
other story making the political
headlines today which is a warning from
the institute for fiscal studies very
respected think tank and quite a
sobering warning suggesting that the tax
cutting plans of both of the leadership
candidates are implausible given the
high rates of inflation that we're
seeing
yesterday of course we learned that
inflation had risen to 10.1 percent in
july
a fresh 40-year high on top of which
there are new reports about the cost of
living crisis impacting perhaps
two-thirds of the country into fuel
poverty um
by the end of the year both candidates
have kind of seized on this response mr
cleverley they're really doubling down
um on liz truss's policies saying she's
going to stimulate economic recovery
with these cuts but mr sunak's saying uh
uh their analysis drives a coach and
horses through her policy well soon see
won't we uh mad if i thank you
but let's stick with the a-level results
out today
so many people on days let this just go
i'm so glad that i don't have to set
exams anymore it's someone though with
i'm sure a slightly different view
rebecca warren is head teacher at most
born community academy in hackney great
to see you this morning um are you as
nervous as your students
absolutely it feels as a head teacher
that you take exams every year
well do you know what from from from my
perspective i'm not going to tell you
how many years ago it was since i did
mine but yeah it was it's certainly more
than you certainly more than you and so
how has it been looking um for your kids
this year no one can deny that this
particular educational cohort has been
through the ringer in terms of the
effect that covert has had on
their personal lives as well as as their
education how are you thinking the
results are going to go
i think we'll have a jubilant year i
think the children will be
excited to be here this morning nervous
of course it's it's all it's a rite of
passage um
they were extremely calm in the run-up
to the exams in fact this year has been
one of the calmest years i've seen in 27
years of teaching
so i'm very much looking forward to
seeing them all sharply at eight o'clock
to receive their results
um so what then happens today there will
be uh well speaking to the education
secretary earlier i mean he believes
that the majority of people will still
be able to get into the into their first
choice
establishment but there will be those
kids
young adults i should say you know who
miss out miss out perhaps more
considerably than they even expected
possible who then have to go into the
clearing process how do you help them at
a time like this
it's about making sure that they feel
supported but they also feel empowered
to make the decisions that are right for
them and for their future so the process
of them deciding on a career pathway
begins much earlier as far back in years
as in year 7 so to speak but in terms of
the handful of students that we'll have
to help today they will very much be
given one-to-one support
scouring looking at what is available
for them and what is right for them
and then obviously giving them the
independence to make the decisions that
they are most comfortable with
and rebecca really quickly if we can we
asked the education secretary about
ventilation covered ventilation going
into schools this morning he didn't seem
to have much of an answer have you had
anything from the government on this
no we haven't um in terms of ventilation
we're we're a very ventilated building
and a lot of our exams where the results
will be given in a huge area so that
isn't something that i'm concerned about
but i've heard nothing from the dfe
about it
i will look rebecca we will get you on
you have a very very busy day i'll keep
my fingers crossed for all your kids
rebecca warden thanks so much for being
with us
wonderful thank you so much bye-bye
take care
uh but let's turn back to afghanistan as
indeed we have all week the taliban
promised a more moderate version of the
brutal rule they imposed last time they
ran the country in the 90s but in the
year since seizing back power some of
their actions have confirmed the worst
fears of human rights activists joining
us from manchester is former afghan
family court judge at martial baba babar
kale who fled afghanistan in 2008 he
stood for election as a labour
councillor in oldham this year but
speaking to us in our own capacity and
maja great to see you this morning um
you know firsthand just what what the
taliban can be capable of
tell us about your experiences at their
hands
my good morning
my experience with the taliban is the
worst experience like other refugees
they have the same
uh twice they tried to kill me in
afghanistan and pakistan
but i did i didn't did anything wrong
just i stand for what i believe
and my work and my passion was not
popular with the taliban that was the
reason they tried to kill me
so once again
we see the taliban reverting to type
back in 2001 when they entered kabul
they did say that they would guarantee
those rights that that women had had
earned
in the absence of the taliban what is
your assessment of how afghan women are
are treated currently it does feel like
we're right back to to pre-2001
conditions
i think when the taliban has retooked
afghanistan women's life across the
country
have been fundamentally changed their
rights curtailed
and freedomly struck by the taliban
there is there is no hope for women in
afghanistan and i think this is the day
the day
the date of our freedom of speech the
freedom of our work the freedom of our
life
i mean of course you are a judge
yourself in afghanistan i i wonder if
you've managed to keep in contact with
any of your
your former colleagues some female
judges clearly do still remain there and
i wonder how how things are for them
yes i'm in contact with my colleagues in
afghanistan 80 judges left in
afghanistan in the very bad condition
security safety
and
financially difficult challenges
these still in afghanistan
it's very difficult for their children
for their husband
for this for them as well because they
moving around
they have no
safety or there is no place to go and
complain if you're not feel safe in
afghanistan this is a big problem for
all the activists for churches for the
people that work with the government
the taliban searching for judges
and
recently one of our female church
was passed away we are not very sure
we have not more details but very sad in
our in our legal family
um marzia babakkar kyle thank you so
much for joining us this morning
appreciate your time
let's turn now to assadulationwari who
fled the taliban's former regime as a
teenager later returned to work as a
government adviser in the years after
they were toppled in 2001 joining us
from leicester uh asado good to see you
this morning um
what is your
appraisal of the current situation in
afghanistan at the moment the way in
which the taliban are operating and
indeed they can the human
humanitarian disaster that appears to be
developing there right now
a morning is a such a nightmare it's
absolutely a nightmare
and i have to say this
it's not just for me for every afghan
and my heart goes to the people
the one who's got their families and to
all of those afghans
i just
feel devastated there's nothing
which is we could do now for them
the situation is getting worse
especially for female
the people who work for the afghan
government before
the national army for the police for the
intelligence services
and also for ordinary afghan people
there's still about 35 million people
are stuck in there
and only in small fracture of them have
managed to get out
but the worst part is just coming
it's been months and months the u.n has
been asking there's going to be a
humanitarian disaster
and the world needs to help
but unfortunately
we
as a country
have been betrayed by the west and by
americans and it shouldn't have happened
in the 21st century and right now after
the war in ukraine
people have forgot about afghans
and is
not fair on afghan people at all
um
i'm really sorry and we're going to have
to leave the interview there but we
appreciate your time we'll try and get
you back on in future so we can continue
this thanks for joining us
uh but of course one of the big stories
of the day and indeed of the week of the
weekend uh problems perhaps on on the
railways and elsewhere but let's head to
the picket lines of the latest round of
strikes on our rail networks uh very
pleased to say uh joining us now the rmt
general secretary general at mick lynch
at london houston uh mr lynch great to
have you on the program this morning um
i wonder if you could start by just by
just reminding our viewers the purposes
of these strikes what it would take
for you to step away from the pickets
well we've still got the issues at the
start the the companies network rail and
the train operators want to cut
thousands of jobs from our industry and
we think that will have an impact on
safety and obviously our members
future they want to rip up our
conditions of service
the train operating companies is also
attacking our pensions and of course we
haven't had a pay deal across much of
the industry for two or three years so
our members are feeling the effects of
the cost of living crisis but they're
also worried about their futures
we need to negotiate a settlement with
14 train operating companies and network
rail we're seeking to do that virtually
every day of the week
but i think the obstacle here at the
moment is the stance of the
the minister grant shaps
and backed up by the treasury and i
think that's got a bit uh wound up with
the conservative party leadership
uh process so if we can get uh the
companies negotiating freely
without being shackled by the government
we can negotiate a settlement for this
dispute and get the railways back to to
running fully
i mean
you'll you'll accept i i'm sure that it
is difficult for those of us who are not
sitting around the negotiating table to
judge what is being said by both sides
we're simply not in the room so when the
government say that that the rmt and on
behalf of their members have rejected an
eight percent pay rise that wouldn't
include compulsory redundancies i mean
is that true or not and and if it is
true why the rejection
so that is an offer for for network rail
and it's at half of this dispute on the
train operating companies we've hadn't
haven't had an offer at all but it also
means that we would have to accept
massive changes to our members working
lives that at this time are unpalatable
and unacceptable the offer is also over
three years it's not an eight percent
offer for this year we didn't get a pay
deal last year it's four percent this
year and four percent next year so it's
eight percent over three years
inflation yesterday came out the retail
price index at twelve point three
percent there are predictions for next
year that it could be up to fifteen
percent
so we could what they're asking us to do
is accept the gamble that next year
our members might receive a quarter of
the rate of inflation
and of course this year when the deal
should have been struck
it was 7.1 so if you
if you add those together it could have
been well over 20 22
something in that region and they're
asking us to accept eight
yesterday there was a deal done on the
bus services in the north at 11.1
we've had a deal done in the aviation
industry of 12 and 13 this week so
they're not offering us anything really
they're offering a real term pay cut
just and a pay cut against the rate of
inflation at that time at this time
that's not acceptable to our people
sorry to interrupt there we're really
pushing for time i just want to kind of
drill down into this particular point
everyone is we saw cpi inflation at 10.1
yesterday the expectation is that that
will rise to 13 by the end of the year
who knows what it will do in the first
six months of of next year but you could
say as a likelihood it could go could go
even higher does that mean that the
rmt's negotiating positions is directly
linked to where inflation might be in
the future or where it is now i mean if
they were to offer you 10 this morning
would you take it
well they're not going to offer me 10
this morning so that's a high percentage
you do get the point you you do get the
point that if we were to accept four
percent for this year and four percent
for next year our members would be
poorer as a result of that deal so the
reference point that we use is the
retail price index other people use the
consumer's price index what we've got to
do is get a package and it's not just
about pay it's about jobs if you haven't
got a job you're not going to get a pay
rise anyway it's about the people's
conditions of service where they want
them to work
more on social hours and we're already
working they want them to change
the way they work and on the train
operating companies which is the
majority of railway workers in this
country we haven't got a pay off at all
and we haven't had one for three years
at the same time they're threatening to
close every booking office in this
country and take all the guards off the
trains so grant shap said that at the
weekend that he wants a guardless
railway service we can't accept any of
that so we've got some real difficulties
to to address and we will do that
to companies through negotiations
apologies for interrupting we've
literally got two minutes left in the
program i do just want to try and
squeeze in another couple of questions i
mean in your mind how close are we to a
general strike
well only the cuc can call a general
strike what we're seeing across the
country i address to meeting thousands
of people last night addressed a massive
one in glasgow on tuesday there is a
wave of reaction
uh amongst working people to the way
they're being treated people are getting
poorer every day of the week people
can't pay their bills they're getting
treated despicably in the workplace i
think there will be generalized and
synchronized action it may not be in the
traditional form but we've seen the the
post office workers and bt
we've seen the bus workers in london out
on strike tomorrow and over the weekend
i think there is a massive response
coming from working people because
they're fed up with the way they're
being treated it's starting to look at
look a little bit like a general strike
look as things stand quite clearly i
think people understand you've got your
majority of public support on your side
and certainly the rmt and and other
unions are suggesting that you can
afford to carry on striking for months
do you accept though with the way
inflation is going there will come a
point where when your house your members
can afford you going on strike
the rest of the country can't afford you
going on strike lower paid workers can't
afford to afford you going on strike
well nobody can afford to go on strike
they don't want to be on strike they
want a settlement but they are
completely
tied into this dispute i addressed the
meeting of thousands of our members last
night online and they are totally
committed to the campaign that we've got
they understood the issues when they
voted for it and they're showing on the
picket lines that they're completely
committed to the cause we will keep
going until we get a negotiated
settlement and our members will decide
whether it's acceptable or not
lynch we're just literally about to go
into the commercial break so i thank you
for squeezing that answer and we'll
speak again
[Music]